so today we're going to talk about
Pascal's triangle it's one of my
favorite things in math particularly
because whenever I talk to other
mathematicians they always have some
interesting patterns they like talking
about it's almost never the same one so
Pascal's triangle is sort of like an
addition triangle so we start with the
number 1 and every time I draw one
assume that everything around it is a
bunch of zeroes so what we do is we have
one and then we add whatever's to the
left of it let's neighbor here is zero
and we just drop that down in between us
and I do the same thing on the right all
right cool now I have two ones in this
row and I'll do the same thing so
there's a zero we can imagine here so we
drop that down there's one in this
neighbor now so we can have a two and
then there's one in this zero to its
right so we make another one and we just
keep doing this for awhile and you can
see that the triangle just keeps getting
bigger this is nothing that's going to
stop so you can just keep doing this for
as long as we want and for me as long as
I want is when the first double digit
number shows up because that's when
adding gets hard
so Pascal was also a convener tourist so
in particular like problems where I have
n things that I want to choose K of them
how many different ways can I do that
and it turns out that Pascal's triangle
it's really like child like adding game
as it seems to be actually encodes n
choose K so if I have n things in
particular let's say I have four things
and I want to choose let's say one of
them then I go to the fourth row I move
over one and that's how many ways I can
do it four ways if I have four things
let's say I have like four circles and I
want to only choose one of them there
are four ways I can do that right I can
choose this one I can choose that one
you can choose that one just that one
and it turns out Pascal's triangle says
if I go down to the fourth row where is
like this is a zero with row and I
choose one thing so I move one over and
that's exactly how many ways I can do it
so if I told you to choose two circles
then there are six ways to do it you
notice that the sides are always ones
like this isn't going to change because
we just keep doing one plus zero and
then oh look one plus zero 1 plus zero
it's just going to keep happening so we
can define this entire diagonal as plus
zero because every time I go down one
I'm not changing anything well then I
get to this row right and we have one
plus one plus one plus one because I
have zero
two three four five so I can define this
row if I felt like it as plus one then
this this pattern looks less fun right I
have one three but the difference
between three and one is two the
difference between six and three is
three the difference between ten and six
is four so it turns out this pattern is
plus 1 plus 2 Plus 3 keeps going so
around here one would be tempted to look
for more patterns like right here is
like plus what 3 plus 6 but that's when
you start to notice what we've been
doing all along which was just adding
contempor to the top left like Pascal
wanted us to anyway let's just look at
something else that one might be tempted
to do when they see a bunch of numbers
and that's add them in a different way
so this is 1 1 plus 1 is 2
1 plus 2 plus 1 is 4 1 plus 3 is 4 plus
3 is 7 plus 1 is 8 you'll notice at some
point I just stopped adding because we
can actually rewrite everything over
here as the powers of 2 so the sum of
the rows of Pascal's triangle is 2 like
if I'm on the nth row and I call the
first one row zero then the sum of that
row is 2 to the N let's just read these
as numbers let's not add them let's not
treat them as anything else
so the first row is 1 the next row is 11
next row is 121 next row is 1331 and we
get 14 6 4 1 and then we get to this so
right now these are actually the powers
of 11 2
so this next row looks pretty
frightening because if I wrote it out
just as it is I get a pretty big number
right like once I put in these commas
this is around 15 million that's not a
little to the bone it's not but it turns
out Pascal's you know his triangle
doesn't quit that early so what's
happening here is that when I was
writing these as digits before I was
actually considering that place value
right like the one place the tens place
the hundreds place so I'm just going to
do the same thing where I rewrite these
numbers as ones in tens and hundreds
place so the first one will be 1 times
10 to the 0 because this is the 0th row
then we have 1 times 10 to the 1 plus 1
ten to the zero so this one's one this
one's 11 let's do one times 10 squared
plus 1 times 2 times 10 to the 1 my bad
plus 1 times 10 to the 0 that's 121 so
let's let's skip on down to our friend
here we do 1 times 10 to the 5 plus 5 10
to the 4 plus 10 10 to the 3 plus 10 10
squared yeah 5 to the 10 to the 1 and 1
times 10 to 0 and this is 11 to the 5 is
11 to the 5 it is 11 to the 5 it's just
hiding so now I have this really cool
thing that I found extremely recently
call them the hockey sticks method I
think some people call it it's just a
really cool trick that you can do on
Pascal's triangle another result of the
fact that it's the coefficients of like
a binomial expansion which is all of it
will make more sense once I draw a
hockey stick what you do is you pick a
one somewhere on the edge and you just
go down diagonally so I'm going to pick
this one and then I'm going to go down
to a million and then I'm just going to
keep going and then at some point I'm
just going to veer off in this case I
have to veer off because I didn't draw
any more rows so the number that I veer
off to is the sum of all the numbers I
trace down one plus two plus three plus
four equals 10 so this row or this
diagonal rather equals 10 so I'm gonna
start with this one and it's going to be
off real quickly actually I'm just going
to all right so works on small ones
let's use this one because why not we
can do the other direction right and we
get one plus two plus three equals six
I'm going to do Pascal's triangle mod
two so brief aside mod two in this case
is just going to mean that every time a
number is odd I write it as a one and
every time a number is even I write it
as a zero so cool right that's still a
tough school song
yeah just mod - it doesn't like
preserved
the actual value of the numbers as much
but it totally tells you whether or not
something's even are out and that's all
we care about right now so then I'm
going to outline all of the diagonals
that are all ones and all the roads that
are all one so I'm going to do this
which isn't the world's prettiest thing
but it's pretty nice and this shape
should maybe start to look a little
familiar if you played on a Legend of
Zelda before it's also the Triforce but
more importantly it's sierpinski
triangle so for those who don't
recognize your pesky triangle I start
with an equilateral triangle I inscribe
another one upside down and then I can
just keep doing this on all of the
upward facing triangles as many times as
I want
so yeah this can just go on for a long
time and it turns out that the way that
the evens and odds show up in Pascal's
triangle when I convert them to mod - I
can make Pascal's triangle as big as I
want and I'm just going to keep getting
iterations of sequential triangle so
that's really cool
it's really good by itself but it gets
cooler using the mod two construction
there's something else we can do in mod
two though in particular we can write
down the same things but let's write
them now is we've got ones and zeros
right and for most people ones and zeros
kind of remind them of binary so let's
just see what happens when we transcribe
these from binary you know one binary 1
and then 1 1 in binary is 3 1 0 1 is 5 1
1 1 is 15 and then the next one 1 0 0 0
1 is 17 now these may not immediately
appear pretty cool but if I kept going
the next one is 51 the next one is 85
after that is 255 and here I'm going to
stop and I'm going to look at what these
numbers are 3 is prime 5 is prime
15 is 5 times 3 17 is prime 51 is 17
times 3 85 is 17 times 5 and 255 is 17
times 15 so you'll notice that every
time I get a prime I go back and just
multiply by all the things that came
before and I can generate the next you
know n minus 1 entries so the prime is
that we have here actually at least the
ones that I'm that were certain of are
actually format Prime's for Fermont
Prime's rather which means that they can
be written of the form 2 to the 2 to the
n plus 1 somehow every time I talk to a
mathematician even 10 minutes ago when I
asked a different mathematician for an
idea he told me something I had never
heard before it so even if maybe
somewhere out in the world all of the
things you couldn't do with this
triangle are done I don't know if
there's any one person who knows them
all and maybe there's only one person
who knows one of them and we just have
to keep exploring this triangle and
seeing if we can collaboratively explain
everything inside of it but it's an
infinite triangle right so maybe there
are things on the hundredth line down
that we haven't explored yet I feel like
it wouldn't be a numberphile video if
somehow the Fibonacci sequence didn't
show up so I'm going to show you what if
it been a few sequences in the Pascal
triangle because it's a numberphile
video so what we're going to do is we're
going to add up the shallow diagonals so
what that means here is the triangle
kind of inscribed diagonals already
right like I could look at this one and
just kind of follow this but a shallow
diagonal means that I'm going to kind of
go off at a slightly higher angle than I
would have if I was just following the
way I drew this triangle so for example
the first Fibonacci number is 1 so
that's my shallow diagonal and then this
one doesn't have any other shallow
neighbors so it's just by itself also
now we have 1 1 so this shallow diagonal
is a 1 and then this one so we do this
you get 2
then we do this one with this too we get
three we do this one with this three
with this one we get five and you know
how this game goes so we have one four
and three here so we're going to get
eight we get I'm going to do one more in
case you don't believe me we're going to
do five plus six plus one and this one
down here that I didn't address and we
get 13 cool so they have it
the two biggest recurrence relations in
math that involve addition probably a
tied together in the triangle they're
not unique things you know you can have
one it encodes the other and it's all
just related in really beautiful ways
it's so beautiful
you know this triangle has all of these
really cool properties about it and
again like you said earlier it feels
like it's really childlike thing right
like I just you know add the things next
to me and I just popped them down under
but I've been playing with this triangle
since I want to say eighth or ninth
grade and I learned half of these things
in the past once and there are still
other things that I could ramble on
about about this triangle and this isn't
even my field like I'm still an
undergraduate I don't even study this
triangle professionally so just imagine
what people know about this triangle
that I don't even know that they don't
even know amongst themselves like it's
amazing